the difference is in the communication
methods if you play with strangers
everybody's going to be taught unless
they go through discord uh everybody's
going to be talking through chat
and it's a lot harder to the the gym of
this game comes not from the game itself
but from
the content surrounding the game so the
hilarious accusations the people turning
like monopoly like
it's the ruiner of friendship
[Music]
so peter if that's your real name
are you peter or are you an imposter
uh i don't know what you're talking
about
i think you do i think you're a sus
okay who are you and what have you done
with uh
the host richard garner so yes for
people at home and for you
it is your old pal richard here but yes
that is
among us lingo that we will be here the
cultural phenomenon that is sweeping the
world by the millions and billions
yeah so i get it now the wildly popular
game among us is what you're talking
about
uh very popular among in among us yes
it is very popular among us and
so we want to take a deeper dive into
this and obviously from the perspective
of this
particular show would have discussed
what if among us
was real oh people will be very excited
i think so and uh but of course i'm not
trying to fool anybody here
i'm not the person to probably lead that
charge
no or answer those questions you look
like a twitch gamer yeah
nor are you so that's why we bring in
experts like
leanna rupert from gameinformer
thanks for making yourself afk and yes i
did learn that
yesterday um leanna how are you welcome
to what if discussed
i am great thank you for having me i'm
excited to talk among us those
those sus little astronaut jelly beans i
ha i actually have in your in your bio
uh self self identified among us
obsessive
and i didn't make that was actually your
words right
it is i uh this game it's so crazy this
game uh has been out for a couple years
but only hit popularity
recently and i totally fell off the map
i didn't hear about it
until i started seeing it climb on
twitch and i checked it out and it's
it's the perfect game it's it's simple
in an era where gaming is all
overwhelming open worlds and
it has to either be game of the year or
nothing at all like the simplicity of
among us
is refreshing and i think with 2020 kind
of needed
like we need just to relax and just
chill and it also kind of gives a an
outlet of rage
because you literally just accuse each
other and yell around a table
until somebody wins or somebody loses
and that's a good outlet for just
letting out some of the rage of
whatever's going on in the world so it's
a game that's being played by millions
it's being watched and streamed by
billions um
some of the most compelling tick tock
content that's that's out there right
now
and you mentioned it was launched in
2018
why do you think it's taken so long and
uh
why is it so popular right now basically
just in the last month
yeah it's uh it's kind of crazy like i
feel like the gaming industry as a whole
has kind of
reinvented how it approaches indie
developers like i think
years ago i think and these were like
this notion
but no big websites no big platforms
were really devoting a lot of time to it
and then we saw games like
uh fall guys that kind of dominated
which is another game about jelly beans
that came out and i think over the last
i would say like 18
19 months or so indies have really been
kind of revolutionized and given a
pedestal
which is deserved in the industry um but
yeah
at first i think personally i mean we
saw a big jump in it on twitch and
that's where the popularity came from
you know twitch
streamers influencers they're really an
official marketing arm now
uh for a lot of games um i go to a lot
of press events and things and now
the ratio between journalists and
influencers is
is very up and down because that is
that's a big queue of marketing and
so we saw like a lot of people on twitch
but then everybody's kind of attributing
twitch being the reason why it's so
popular but i don't think it would have
even become a thing on twitch
if we didn't have the game by mediatonic
which is fall guys
which is a game that actually got
rejected many times by
publishers because they didn't think it
would do well and then the twitter
account i think gained a million
followers within
um less than a month maybe two weeks i
think and that came its own phenomenon
but it's the little jelly bean
design so i think people were looking
for that kind of a stylation of games
and that's when
a few key gamers happened to stumble
upon
you know another little jelly bean
astronaut adventure with among us and it
went from
having a usual average concurrent player
base of eight players worldwide
two million of millions of players are
now invested in this and so that's kind
of a nice little
conjunction between indirect indie
relativity
and the power of streamers hmm
i mean it's an interesting thing and you
you referenced it uh
you know the old keep it simple stupid
or kiss right i mean that's come up
throughout
you know it's sort of circles back
throughout history where
when something blows up people often
sort of resort back to well it just
it seemed to hit people in this area in
this area and
whatever it is the product it blew up it
just sort of you know
caught people by storm this is the case
but as it relates to gaming
and you talked about it off the top
complexity became the default right
just incredibly ostentatious
worlds highly skilled highly talented
players
and now you have something come along
that's right
i don't want to say it's lo-fi certainly
simpler but also more accessible because
you don't have to be a fantastic gamer
to play this right
yes uh i think we kind of saw that with
the big aoc
stream uh lately was uh
so i watched that i was like is aoc
playing among us
with was it valkyrie or valkyrie or
pokeman like a bunch of really big uh um
like it was it was a crazy turnout and
she does play
games like i i think she's a big league
of legends fan but she's not
known as a gamer she's not like like
some of us where
it's like our lives like that's all
she's doing some other stuff she's a
little busy
she's a little busy you know she's a
little busy but yeah
no i think it's very accessible um you
know there's
the little death animations but it's
nothing graphic other than i guess the
next snap would be kind of considered a
little graphic but the
the art style makes it accessible kind
of to all ages
you don't have to be a pro gamer to yell
at somebody saying they look suspicious
um it's it's almost funnier if you have
inexperienced gamers on it because they
don't
know kind of the talk and the lingo and
that
naitivity kind of actually works in
their favor i remember my first match i
ever did
i never played the game i didn't know
how it worked and i was imposter the
first time
and i didn't know you had to find tasks
pretend like you were doing them i
didn't know
so i kept asking a chat like what am i
doing like where where do i go do i go
here or do i go here
and it kind of appealed to my teammates
um natural want to help me
to learn the game perfect cover yeah
yeah it was the perfect cover so when i
saw that worked and it was unintentional
i wasn't being manipulative i was
genuinely so confused i was like
wait that worked i could use that going
forward so if you ever play with
me i just told myself that wasn't it
yeah well the big uh the big what if for
us today is what if among us was
real but uh it seems like we may be a
little late to the party or the
the parties
uh i think i think it's a little crazy i
mean there are there's
there was a fan that created like a vr
version
of among us that kind of makes it a
little bit easier oh that's interesting
yeah yeah
uh that was really awesomely made
um it was really well done and it kind
of does put you in that mindset of like
what if i was just doing random tasks
and electrical and somebody just
a friend just came up and killed me like
i don't think we could ever be walking
jelly beans but
you know it's i think it's implausible
these are all
self-contained maps of being on a
spaceship and
oxygenized and everything i don't think
it's that far-fetched
i don't know why we would want to do it
and a bit of a reboot of like you know
like
you know it's like everything old is new
again so there's you know that sort of
uh mystery dinner theater
clue yeah you know wink murder like
who's
you know who's who's lying basically who
who killed people who's lying and
and the rest of the group trying to
figure it out right like it's
there's a lot of different i i play a
little poker
and that's obviously for the kids at
home because i play a lot of poker
but it's interesting because again when
you start to zoom out
and look at where are the commonalities
in human behavior that
when something goes massive you have to
start to you know look at what is the
what is the common denominator and
you know if i i was looking at it from a
poker lens and i was thinking that
there's two different types of
experiences for poker like
there's the you know there's the the
home game with your buddies
and that's a really you know that's
that's more social and more fun
right but also when it's your friends
easier to know when they're
full of it right like a little bit
easier yeah not always but if you've
known somebody for 20 years
and you know their moves right you know
their tells if you will
like leanna's uh yeah exactly but
her sort of oh my god i know what i'm
doing if yeah i got friends if they were
doing that right away you're the
imposter
and but also what i've noticed is
it's an entirely different experience
when i play with strangers friends you
know if you're in vegas or
at a casino and i i enjoy both for
different reasons
what for you do you think is is maybe
the optimum and maybe it's a personal
choice
um to wait uh optimum way to play among
us
is it with friends or with people you
don't know
definitely better with friends because
if you're not really if you if you
play with straight the difference is is
in the communication methods
if you play with strangers everybody's
going to be taught unless they go
through discord
uh everybody's going to be talking
through chat and it's a lot harder to
the the the gem of this game comes not
from the game itself but from
the content surrounding the game so the
hilarious accusations the people turning
like monopoly like it it's the ruiner of
friendships this is
wow this is this is the new halo
multiplayer where
your friendships will be tested you just
reminded me honestly like of
of really like absolutely wildly intense
board-throwing peace-throwing fi family
fights
monopoly back in the day like it was
crazy it is like the absolute
and so and i'm guessing in this because
i have watched some videos like people
do
go nuts they yeah they it's
it's so funny we were playing a match
we're actually gonna be playing again
this weekend
uh but we are playing a match with a
couple of the game and former folks and
some of the people from the washington
post and
and it's so funny because in public
because we're you know all journalists
we're very like
well they are i'm i'm not but they're
very professional and put together
and yes you know how do you do and then
we go in this among us and it's just
masks off claws out like no you're lying
and just like no just shut your mouth
you're lying and just
everything like ambitions go to the wind
because nothing matters when it comes to
proving that you're not
sus you're not the imposter even if you
are
and then you've got the other mechanics
of which i learned actually this weekend
for the first time is
the third imposter of if a person is not
the imposter
but they suspect who is but they want to
help them for some reason
that they will purposely misdirect and
blame other people
i don't understand why that's a thing i
don't understand um what benefit there
is to that but i've been accused of that
a lot because
apparently i have no intuition when i
think i've
caught somebody or i'm like they're
acting really suspicious i'm nine times
out of ten wrongs
so i've been accused of being a third
imposter a lot it's like no
i'm just dumb i guess it's a
psychological profile machine it sounds
like
well it really is lyanna it's
interesting because
i think what the world would least need
at this point is a is a game that
divides us into factions
creates liars creates better liars yeah
this is not something that uh that
we're really should be looking forward
to like i guess also i guess the glass
half full
rage outlet yeah rage outlets
we'd love it if you could stick around
for a few more questions if you can
absolutely perfect where can people find
and follow you and and read your reviews
of uh
of among us and other games uh you can
find me at gameinformer.com
um my social information is on there as
well please don't make fun of me it's my
every my tag for everything is is an old
gamertag joke
uh it's dirty f and hippies i was gonna
ask you i'm glad you brought that up
because i want to know what the source
of that was
uh when i was active duty um everybody
in my unit made fun of me because i
always no matter where we were if we
were in the middle east
or if i was on a ship they oh i always
had my guitar
i'm basically that that that uh i was
the sailor but i went grade sign to the
marines but i was basically the one
that's like so anyway here's wonderwall
[Laughter]
i remember when we were in the middle
east i was like sweat you know you're
wearing
100 plus pounds of of equipment it's
really hot i was really sweaty i was
really gross like it was just like
sweat was just hair was like plastered
and i was like yo
so anyway and i started playing they're
like man she's such like a dirty hippy
and i was like you know what i like it
let's do it like you can't really insult
me if you insult me i just kind of
adapt it so i was like yeah i'm dirty up
and hit me and it just kind of stuck
i i i just love the idea of somebody in
like sort of you know full military
you know you're my one that's all i can
play on guitar too
yes yeah okay great stuff uh we'll be
back with uh leanna rupert uh
after the break um and if you want to
listen if you're watching and you want
to listen
yeah you'll find the link below right
yeah if you want to hear more from
lyanna we're going to check in with her
on the other side if you're watching
the video podcast on youtube then you're
going to want to click the link
for the extended audio podcast below
we're going to dive in more about the
company behind among us
inner sloth and the possibility of a
sequel to the game
um but if that's all the time you have
for us thanks for coming out
and thanks for watching what if
[Music]
discussed